عدنا والعود احمد ورجعنا لكم بعد اجازه مو
طويله كثير وطبعا كالعاده وزي ما هو
ملازمنا في نشراتنا من زمان ايلون ماسك
بيستقبلنا بخبر هو عنواننا الاول فماسك يا
جماعه انهى الجدل والانتظار الطويل وكشفوا
واخيرا عن هويه رئيس تويتر الجديد تعالوا
بس نتذكر القصه من الاول ماسك من وقت ما
اشترت وتر وتراس الشركه وهو عامل جدل لعده
اسباب ومن هذه الاسباب تراسلي الشركه
فيعني في ناس شايفه انه كيف ماسك حيدير
تويتر ومعها تسلا ومعها سبيس اكس كمان هذا
غير سلسله القرارات الجدليه اللي اخذها
وطبعا غير الحاله الماديه الصعبه للشركه
وغير موجه التسريحات الكبيره اللي عملها
وامام طبعا كل هذا الصخب والانتقادات عمل
ماسك استفتاء لمتابعي في ديسمبر وسالهم هل
بتفضلوا استمر في رئاسه تويتر وتعهد
بالالتزام بالنتيجه والناس اختارت انه
يتنحى وطلع بعدها واكد انه حيتنحى وانه
قبل اخر السنه في رئيس جديد حيمسك تويتر
الخميس غرد ماسك بالمفاجاه وقال لهم خلاص
اخترت الرئيس الجديد وراح تبدا عملها
الاسابيع الجايه في التغريده ما حدد مين
لكن شوق الناس خصوصا وانه انفهم من الكلام
انها سيده وثاني يوم على طول غرض ماسك
ثاني واعلن هويه رئيس التويتر الجديده وهي
ليندا يا كروني وقال انه راح تتراس الشركه
وتركز على عملياتها فيما حيركز ماسك على
تصميم المنتجات
والتكنولوجيا الجديده الرئيس التنفيذيه
الجديده قالت بعد تعيينها انه لطالما
الهمتها رؤيه ماسك للمستقبل وانه سعيده
ومتحمسه للمساعده في تحويل هذه الرؤيه
لواقع
السؤال طبعا الكل بيساله الان مين هي
ليندا يا كروني ليندا كانت وحتى قبل
تعيينها من قبل ماسك بتشغل منصب مديره
الاعلانات في ام بي سي يونيفرسال وبتشتغل
مع الشركه من 2011 يعني من اكثر من 12 سنه
لكن من اسابيع عملت مقابله مع مصر في
مؤتمر تسويق في ميامي ويبدو انه هنا حصل
الكليك اما قبل ام بي سي يونيفرسول فلندا
بتشتغل في مجال الاعلان والتسويق من 30
سنه تقريبا وكانت اشتغلت كمان على مشاريع
مع ايام رئاسته وكمان مع بايدن خلال
رئاسته الحاليه